you can't grow food on dead soil and 80
percent of Europe's land and sea is in
poor condition we need a European law to
restore nature to help farmers families
all of us
but yet when we try to do this the
conservatives here in the European
Parliament try to block it Muhammad
welcome why do we need a nature
restoration law I mean I think you've
said it quite clearly in the
introduction on that soil we can grow
any crops and if you take climate change
seriously we need to make sure our
ecosystem Civic science is very clear
without a working ecosystems without
making sure that our nature is restored
all our climate policies will not be
successful and now to you Cesar welcome
thank you actually what does the nature
restoration law do okay this law
I think contribute to recuperate these
ecosystems
and the habitats also also species that
they are in a very bad situation not
only in Europe around the world but our
focus is Europe and we need to put
measures to defend the nature and to
recuperate and restorate this ecosystem
I think it's it's crucial for our
history can I say something because it's
really important people and people need
to know the nature is relational is also
about our Healthcare about clean air in
our cities but I mean that's also very
important it's it's not and I think it
goes perfectly in balance with improving
our economy because improving nature is
good for the let's say the the insects
the pollinators it's good for foreign
at the end of the day and hence it's
good for us because it's good for life
and what would you say
looking at how the conservatives behaved
on the nature restoration law would you
say that their behavior is part of a
wider problem I mean I really don't know
I mean it's up to them to look at what I
see is that we try them especially
Caesar we really tried to accommodate
all the comments and all the let's say
questions that were that were raised by
the conservatives and I even in the Envy
vote not even in penalty even before
that if you looked at the compromises we
I mean Caesar tried to accommodate them
substance wise but if you do not look at
substance and you walk away from the
negotiations then it's very hard I mean
after the penalty votes I heard some
conservative state state that they were
quite pleased with the outcome at least
without and still they voted against so
then I questioned them did you read the
outcome after the vote or were you not
aware of the outcome during the vote and
if so why did you vote against I mean
this is a crucial question and we hope
they come back to the table and my
compliments to Cesar for his hard work
and his patience because patience was
really needed in this file but talking
about patience and also what you
mentioned compromise that that sort of
you try to work on the on the compromise
with them
what would you say actually happened
what happened in the parliament
and how did the conservatives try to
stop this law this is a mother
more than a nature restoration law I
think inside the rights in this
parliament in Europe in fact
they have a fight about the boats and I
think they are making a very very big
mistake the central Politics the
progressive politics are the majority in
Europe
them in the conservative what happened
really is a change of the surgery
and in the natural restoration I think
because
always the conservative
wants to put the polities the measures
is low and slow but in this case the
climate change we don't have time today
today is late
yeah but I mean yes the problem is that
one critical groups in the middle start
polarizing then they're feeding the
extremes and when your party has an
identity crisis which is fat I mean I
think many political groups have want to
reinvent themselves to really see where
they stand but if it's just means you're
copying let's say the more far right
parties when it comes to their political
position then basically you're
underlining that position and you're not
Reinventing yourself can you tell me in
a nutshell what is good in the nature
restoration law and why does it help the
people why did the s d group and in
particular the two of you really fight
for it so hardly I mean nature is
something we should all fight for to
improve because it's good for us for
Earth for life itself I mean that's what
I said good for Farmers good for the
animals Etc since 1994 we have the bird
and habitat directive if we see what
European countries have done with it
it's not really let's say super
but if we look at the results
and that's about protecting let's say
protected areas most areas in the EU are
really bad like more than 80 is in bad
shape I think in the Netherlands it's
even 90 and now we say like protecting
certain protected areas is not enough
what we should do is in the future when
we because we know that climate change
is real in order to to take measures uh
to to stop the the heating of Earth the
nature-based solutions are the best way
planting trees in our cities improving
forests outside our cities there are
like almost
a biological Airco within especially
within is it so telling that in the
future at some moment we will start
restoring nature is I think something we
should all underline instead of fight
and and this is I think the best message
we have and that's thanks to Cesar that
we as eu's if we can finalize the
dialogues we'll say that we take nature
seriously not only the product the
Darius but all nature in the EU and we
will do whatever we can to restore our
seas and restore our nature on land
that's something beautiful it's a
beautiful positive message
definitely now let's do a new section
and our take a left podcast of the
Socialists and Democrats and we have a
little quiz the conservatives have been
spreading a lot of myth as we heard
about the nature restoration law
which of the following is not an Epp
claim from Twitter number one it would
make Santa homeless
number two greater tunberg doesn't
support it number three
the legislation is badly thought through
number two I think no Mohammed I never
go against Caesar so go for number two
okay number two it is correct okay
final question to you Cesar what is next
we'll start the negotiations I think we
will be in conditions to approve a deal
with the other groups I
PP recapacitate and we have
possibilities to incorporate to add PP
in the final of the negotiation
and in December maybe January
we can have the first nature restoration
law in our history and it will be
it will be for the SRD and it's a very
very achievement for the SRD group it's
a milestone
thank you thank you to both of you okay
and thank you it was great too
talk to you
well there you have it while the Epp
ignored the science
with the Progressive Majority
we pass this important file
thanks Cesar thanks Muhammad for joining
us whether you're watching us or
listening thanks for joining us for take
a left the podcast from the Socialists
and Democrats in the European Parliament
president
solution is adopted
[Music]